admis pro centre-est du pays on retrouve
tout de suite karim yahiaoui notre
envoyé spécial karim bonsoir alors que
l'offensive russe s'accentue à l'est ni
pro est devenu un e logistique crucial
dans la résistance à cette invasion
ni pro se trouve en quelque sorte face
aux trois fronts avec kharkiv honore le
dombass à l'est et puis carson ville
sous contrôle russe qui se trouve au sud
et c'est vrai que c'est un verrou majeur
si les russes avaient envisagé d'aller
plus loin que le dombass mais c'est
surtout une base arrière aux eaux d'où
partent tous les efforts de résistance
ukrainien il faut savoir que cette ville
denis pro et bien envoyé au front
quelques cinquante mille hommes sous les
drapeaux c'est à peu près un cinquième
de l'ensemble des soldats qui combattent
côté ukrainien mais surtout il ya une
mobilisation ici sans faille avec toutes
les franges de la société qui se
mobilisent à travers des associations
parce que évidemment le pouvoir public
ne s'y fie plus il ya énormément de
mobilisation pour tenter d'aller
chercher des gens qui sont coincés dans
les zones qui sont frappés par les
bombardements russes donc on n'hésite
pas depuis denis pro à partir à bord de
petites camionnettes de voiture pour
aller soit ramené des produits de
produits de première nécessité dans les
régions où la situation est critique
parce que parfois les gens ont refusé de
partir et puis pour ramener des gens
jusqu'à ni pro qui est devenu en quelque
sorte un carrefour où affluent beaucoup
de réfugiés alors évidemment on a parlé
à quelques militaires présents ici il
nous ils ont eu un discours assez
prévisible en et nous expliquant qu'ils
étaient totalement prêts et qu'ils
avaient tout un peuple derrière eux
alors évidemment il ya un discours qui
peut s'apparenter à un discours policé
mais on a tout de même le sentiment
ucciani pro qu' il y a une vraie
mobilisation derrière l'armée
ukrainienne au niveau des civils ni pro
karim vous l'avez évoqué qui vit
aujourd'hui au rythme des vagues de
réfugiés
alors d'après le maire denis pro il
passerait chaque jour quelque 15000
personnes ici dans cette ville alors on
tente d'en accueillir un certain nombre
certains considèrent que ni pro est une
ville suffisamment sûr il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont fui kharkiv quelques
personnes qui ont réussi à échapper à
l'enfer de marioupol et puis beaucoup de
gens qui viennent du dombass alors
certains s'arrêtent un instant ici pour
continuer leur chemin d'autres décident
de rester plus longuement parce qu'ils y
ont quelques attaches en tout cas les
autorités régionales aux fortes à faire
pour faire face à cette situation
humanitaire qui est tout de même
extrêmement compliquée puisque comme je
vous le disais chaque jour des milliers
de personnes arrivent ici à ni pro merci
beaucoup carignan